this is Danny Michael associate curator
of the Buffalo Bill center of the West
Cody Firearms Museum which hosts a wide
array of wild west Weaponry artifacts
and Relics today he's joining us to
break down just a few of the details and
objects found in the world of Red Dead
Redemption 2. he works the lever there
he works the lever to open the action
and when he does that that will eject
the spent case and then as he closes the
lever
that'll pull in the next round in uh
from the magazine tube that's in the
buttstock here I highly recommend
checking out the Buffalo Bill Center the
west and Cody Firearms Museum all of
that information will be in the
description below we have a second part
covering Red Dead Redemption 2 coming
soon so make sure to subscribe for that
and consider this your spoiler warning
for the game if you've not got around to
playing yet but without further Ado
let's see what a wild west expert makes
of Red Dead Redemption 2.
yeah and this looks a lot like period
photos for Western towns this is
probably maybe a little bit earlier time
period you know it's hard to tell
because towns would sort of develop on
their own over time they see a lot of
wood frame structures early on in a
Town's life you know tense really early
and very quickly replaced by like wood
and then eventually replaced by Brick
and Stone buildings as towns developed
in the sort of mid-1860s to late 1800s
you know a lot of them went through that
transformation
um so if the game is sort of 18.99 this
is probably a relatively in theory
recently founded Town that's got
everything you need you got your
Stockyard you have your blacksmith you
got a small hotel
um Saloon a doctor you know the dirt
streets and like some stuff set up with
sort of nice boardwalks and some stuff
just set up next to the road that all
pretty well relates to like period
photographs so if somebody you know goes
and looks at those they'd see that
[Music]
what's your problem
partner hello again like in this in this
clip of one through the city you see a
lot of
pretty common features you know they
seem to have done their homework on like
period photographs of urban cities and
urban locations there's the sort of
stone or cobblestone streets there's the
trolley tracks trolleys were really
popular you know and there's a way to
get around cities at the time that would
last into the 20th century to see what
looks like at that corner a little bit
of like flat iron architecture that's
pretty heavily associated with the 19th
century lots of different shops
hand-painted signs it's really great
detail for the game it like really
builds the environment
and of course you know mention the
Charlie's got to go somewhere if there's
tracks and having that in game as a way
to get around is a really a really nice
touch that you can actually ride around
even if it's not necessarily the fastest
way to instead of sprinting around your
on your horse but yeah I think if
anybody were to sort of go be inspired
by the game to go explore like period
photographs of small towns on the
frontier or Western cities like Denver
or someplace like that you'd find a lot
of similarities to like late 1880s 1890s
and especially in the city
foreign
I think for a city the era you know
there's small markets and cities today
where you can go like a farmer's market
something like that they would have
looked a little bit different this one
you know seems to be intended to be sort
of a lower income Market there's a lot
of different ethnicities represented you
saw um some folks speaking Cantonese and
that's one thing that would be pretty
accurate for the time period
okay sir
right here
hello sir
so Hollywood has kind of given us this
impression that a lot of you know that
Cowboys were mostly white and that's not
really accurate they're Native Americans
there are black there are Hispanic uh
Cowboys a lot of the Traditions come
from those cultures as well that we
think of as Cowboy Traditions that in
itself is of course a Melting Pot the
city scenes like this would have been a
Melting Pot there have been a lot of
immigrants in a city setting like this
in the late 1800s especially if you're
thinking in Western cities with Chinese
immigration that you saw somebody
speaking Cantonese there so yeah this is
a I think a pretty good attempt to to
represent not just the normal
stereotypical Cowboy view of of the Old
West
foreign
so here we see Arthur using uh what in
game is called the carbine repeater but
is based on the real life uh Spencer
repeating uh rifle and carbine uh so
Arthur's using a carbine version that
they made a longer version that was a
rifle those are a lot less common you
can see that Arthur uh he's pretty slick
when he works the the lever on the on
the Spencer so he grabs the hammer there
you can see each time I'm going to pause
it there actually so you see
Arthur working the the lever and the
hammer on a Spencer very quickly and
he's very slick at it it's a little bit
harder than he makes it look in the game
so this is the Spencer carbine based or
what the in-game carbine repeater is
based on very much the same gun they did
a really good job of modeling it in game
um as you'll see in this clip they get
pretty much all the features right
um this one's a what's called a model
1865. there's a couple small variations
on the Spencers but they're generally
very similar
foreign
ERS doing as he works the lever there he
works the lever to open the action and
when he does that that'll eject the
spent case and then as he closes the
lever that'll pull in the next round in
uh from the magazine tube that's in the
buttstock here it's a seven round
magazine which is also accurately
represented in the game and then what
Arthur's doing is he closes that lever
and pulls his hand back on the trigger
he's cocking the hammer all the way back
every time so when he's doing that he's
doing that in one really Swift motion
most people that shoot these or shoot
reproductions of these will do them in
two separate stages but yeah that
Levering and then closing the lever and
then grabbing the hammer are usually
separate steps uh on the Spencer but
Arthur's gotten very good with his so he
can do that in one really slick motion
so see Arthur reload right there and
what he's actually doing is reloading uh
the tubular magazine in the stock you
see this small door I think you can see
it on the screen there
uh you can see that small door
it spins to the side there
that spins to the side
and then
the tube slides out and you can insert a
new tube and Arthur appears to have a
second tube so that he doesn't have to
slow down
and reload
um the first two so there's a couple
ways you can reload these is you can
pull that tube all the way out put seven
new cartridges in the tube and then put
it back in or if you have a second tube
ready to go you can reload it that way
the Spencer is a really interesting
choice I think for sort of the starting
uh long gun of the game after the
American Civil War in the 1860s these
were very common they were they made
over a hundred thousand of these during
the war their most were sold off of
surplus
uh someone to Europe during the
franco-prussian war but a lot were sold
as Surplus in the American West so
somebody like Arthur could have gotten
these very cheaply in the 1860s 1870s by
1890s when the game is set it's probably
pretty outdated uh there probably
weren't many in active use by that point
uh the ammunition is a proprietary
Rimfire cartridge called 5650 Spencer
and
that would have been pretty hard to come
by by the 1899 but an interesting choice
because it would have been very
prevalent in the west as you think about
sort of guns after the Civil War
um this one would have been pretty cheap
and pretty readily available so to me
it's a really really good choice for
sort of your starting long gun in the
game and they do a really good job of
modeling it you have the correct
animations for the lever the the hammer
the reload that's all right Arthur's
probably a little better than most at
using it but that's pretty
understandable for his character so yeah
a really interesting choice and a really
well-modeled choice
oh
you borrowed money from my business
partner hair Strauss you owe him you
took the money he wants it back what's
not to understand
where's our money I don't have it
so here we see uh this man who we learn
is uh kind of ill uh cough and get
something on Arthur and we don't see it
take effect or right away as the game
goes through Arthur gets starts to get
sick and
um gets sick with what's called
consumption or TV for tuberculosis and
one of the things that wasn't well
understood in the late 1800s was how
tuberculosis was spread it was a pretty
common disease it actually impacted a
lot of a lot of people spread pretty
rapidly and could be a really a deadly
disease at that time and one of the
reasons was that folks didn't understand
very well how it spread and of course it
was a highly contagious disease now we
see a little bit later in the game
Arthur is suffering here he's
symptomatic your character is kind of in
and out and doesn't have great vision
tuberculosis would sort of settle in
your lungs and damage your lungs and one
of the the common system or symptoms
excuse me that we see both Arthur both
the guy before him have his coughing and
then eventually coughing up blood it's a
really calm common symptom a lot of the
treatments at the time once they begin
to realize there were treatments were to
send people to drier climates warmer
drier climates like the American
southwest and then once folks began to
to sort of understand the disease a
little better by I actually by the time
the game takes place there have been
just some discoveries made that started
to take hold and help improve treatments
for TB so then you see sort of a
sanatorium movement where folks would go
to stay and they would do a really good
job of trying to keep things clean
because that had an impact on the on the
disease to get people fresh air those
movements to eat healthier those all
things were attempts to help patients
suffering from this and actually in the
late 1890s when the game set it wouldn't
be impossible that Arthur could have
gotten a diagnosis by x-ray actually the
medical x-ray had just been invented in
the mid-1890s and was very quickly used
to start diagnosis so while it's
probably unlikely I wouldn't have been
entirely impossible to get an x-ray here
he's paying the doctor he's pretty
symptomatic some of the common
treatments at the time especially before
the disease was well understood people
would self-medicate with alcohol often
use opium
um or and use both in conjunction Doc
Holiday
famous gunfighter for the okay Corral
he's a well-known person that suffered
from TB and he's well known to have used
whiskey and opium to sort of cope with
his symptoms and kind of stay functional
in spite of a pretty severe case of TB
what is it
it's not good news I guess that
you got tuberculosis
I'm really sorry for you son it's a hell
of a thing
one of the common things about TB was
that it sort of the people suffering
from it would turn sort of kind of pale
a little bit Ashen their skin tone would
change so we see that reflected in
Arthur's appearance here as he as he
suffers from tuberculosis
don't make us hurt you here unlock the
door so we're obviously seeing a bank
robbery here there's actually if you
want to get involved in history at the
academic level there's a there's a
pretty significant well maybe not
significant but there's a niche debate
we'll say about actually how common bank
robberies were in the old west
the general consensus is they're not
that common in the old west some of the
studies you'll see you'll put the number
as low as just like a dozen or so over
several decades I think that's probably
an undercount myself
um but I think the the underlying theme
is right that bank robberies in the west
weren't as common uh as they're
portrayed in uh TV and movies and of
course video games but they do make for
a lot more compelling gameplay than not
rather than the banks one of the reasons
that
bank robberies might have been less
common than we think of is that
one of the things about the old west is
there was sort of a continual physical
currency shortage so it wasn't always
the most lucrative thing to hit the bank
it's also a lot more conspicuous as you
see the gangs trying to get out through
town right here in a small town like
this most people are going to know
what's going on in town that day so
these guys probably would have stood out
and it gives them a lot more chance to
get caught versus like a stagecoach or a
train robbery where they might be out
with a lot less people around so that's
another those are two big deterrents to
bank robberies in the old west having a
lot of people around and the lack of
actual physical currency that was often
short in the West
so here you see a shootout start with
the gang members as they're trying to
leave the Valentine bank and this is
actually in the some of the bank
robberies that are documented in the old
west uh that was a relatively common
occurrence to the bank robberies because
the locals would figure out what's going
on realize that it's their own money
that if they don't get it then they're
not getting it back and would take up
arms uh against the robbers to try and
prevent them from robbing the bank that
happened really famously
um in Minnesota
um I believe and I think I'm getting
that right
um the Northfield robbery um I want to
say and it also happened
um actually here in Cody so where the
Museum's at Cody had his own bank
robbery uh at one point suffice to say
the Cody locals heard there was a bank
robbery going on in town two robbers
attempting to escape uh actually got in
a gunfight outside of the Irma hotel
that's still here in town the original
building that was the bank is now the
jewelry store but there was a shootout
across the street one of the bank
employees was killed the two robbers
managed to make their escape and not get
caught but uh it ended in a shootout in
a Chase with the actual Cody locals
because it was their money on the line
so this scene is you know pretty
representative that the locals would
find out
and potentially even chew back
so here we see Arthur getting into a
quick draw scenario over this slight and
obviously he wins the wins the Quick
Draw there were a few duels in the west
there were gunfights in the west they
tended to look more like what we might
imagine the okay Corral close and
Confused not necessarily the standout in
the street but there were famously at
least a few sort of stand out in the
street Hollywood style duels they got
really popular in dime novels and then
got really popular of course in popular
media because of that they're not nearly
as common as portrayed there's really
just a handful that happened in the west
one of the most famous being Wild Bill
Hickok he got into a duel I think in St
Louis over a pocket watch and a debt he
he allegedly owed the guy insulted a
former friend insulted him over the
pocket watch then he challenged a friend
to effectively a duel and it was very
much based in the sense of a grudge and
a grievance and this score had to be
settled and everybody sort of viewed it
as a thing of honor and so it was very
much the the kind of dual wear two guys
faced off in the street Hickok won that
duel and killed the other guy he was
tried and acquitted for it for murder
but that's just one of a few a few
examples
um just really a handful of examples
throughout the entire Western period I
think that one happened in the late
1860s and there's just a handful more in
the next few decades in the West
[Music]
foreign
if you'd like to see more of Dany as
well as other wild west episodes make
sure to like the video and let us know
in the comments I hope you'll join me in
thanking Danny and the Cody Firearms
Museum for collaborating with us on this
video you can check out some of their
videos as well as all of their other
information in the description below